au kenya
[Musique]
à
on va accueillir carla alors oui mais tu
sais que si tu dis car là ils attendent
un nom de famille enfin gentil oui ah
bah oui excusez moi confie jacky hénin
qui l'est tout perdu là et carla carla
va bien qu'ils attendaient
d'applaudissements pour car la peur qui
suit vous plairait bonsoir m'y attendais
pas
je suis très content d'être avec vous ce
soir je m'appelle carla et je vais vous
parler des migrants microsot mara
méditerranée depuis le début de l'année
non ils sont pas tous à part de la
chapelle à l'ena beaucoup au fond de la
mer et je vous passe tous ceux qui se
sont frigorifiés année sillon de
traverser la frontière franco italienne
ça va bien se passer
la maison du gauche de la salle quand
même
ah d'accord alors pourquoi je vais vous
parler du migrant quelle idée que l'idée
alors parce que moi je suis italienne et
bennett vous savez pas mais chez nous
tout le monde me guay à vous les
français vous êtes champion du monde de
foot
nous nous en champion du monde de
migration et la raison est très simple
en fait on a une arme secrète on peut
aller partout dans le monde on aura
toujours un travail soit ouvre la
pizzeria soit devenir le boss de la
mafia locale
les deux en même temps c'est nickel
s'est mis qu'elle m'aimait plus d'être
parmi vous s'il ya des gens issus de
l'immigration nord des immigrés des
expatriés des sans papiers des doubles
inné des afrodescendants les belges 1 à
la d origine par ci par là manquaient
des français pur souche les italiens
déjà l'événement il y en a ou pas oui
voilà quelques-uns quand vous avez très
honte là quelques origines par ci par là
notre trichez pas français sur quatre
est issu de l'immigration la halle et
oui vous n'avez que ça vient d'où les
origines d'un parfait ensuite des autres
origines ouhlala oui voilà à la
république tchèque exceptionnel sinon d
autrui oui au fonds italien et polonais
magnifique magnifique les autres on va
dire vous êtes d'origine timide 1
d'accord d'accord avec vous dis moi j'ai
une théorie
moi je pense qu'on est tous migrants ah
parce que c'est quelque chose de naturel
les puits la nuit des temps c'est un
instant naturel quand on se sent en
danger quand on a peur aux migrants à
mon mec quand il y en a marre des
m'écouter et quand ils se sont un danger
il migre il migre dans les toilettes
le vôtre et le migou d'un jardin à bas
la chance s'ils ont un jardin en plus
voilà donc je pense banc d'essai en tout
naturel donc vous faire un exemple
imaginons que aux nigériens les terres
soient bienvenues incultivables a causé
des fuites deux hauts lieux du kt de
monsieur total sur ces riant jean vente
à eybens les nigériens on pourra pas les
arrêter ils vont arriver ici on peut
leur dire tout ce qu'on veut n'envie ni
pai à la grève ou les pris en otages par
les grévistes non vie n'est pas marine
lé père est devenu président de la
république c'est pour bientôt savez nos
vies n'est pas il faut du temps que
celle où il met de la crème fraîche dans
la carbonara l'algérie va on peut leur
dire tout ce que vous voulez ils vont
arriver quand même a juste un peu plus
écorché de regarder regarder les
mexicains ils veulent toujours aller aux
états unis même si aulas me donald trump
à l'arrivée les indonésiens veulent tous
aller en australie
même si elle fait ça parce que toute
façon ils ont les ordinations à l'ailé
sud américains veulent tous aller au
brésil
moi aussi je vais aller au brésil tout
le monde valeo précise même s'il ya un
pyromane au pouvoir n'ont donc
franchement on est d'accord ou pas on
est d'accord au bac c'est en tout cas
naturel a débouché je me sens très
convaincu se faire un nom mais moi je
faisais vraiment mais je suis convaincu
moi c'est comme les animaux c'est comme
c'est comme les baleines les tortues les
les flammes à rose vous savez qui me
grenon et imagine au imaginons des
flamants roses c'est parler comme ça
fait un effort l'art d'imagination salut
je suis arrivé ici dalghar cette année
migrera le gars qu'est ce qui te fait
ici tu ne veux pas me griller à
s'alarmer giroud au le stopper les
humains mais ferme bord des lacs une
pompe à eau là bas je peux plus y aller
il ya plein de plastique qui a plus
crétins messieurs n'a pas été fait pour
toujours aussi mal ça leur donne mais ça
veut regarder semblables de gretel et
les portables tout ça mais c'est pas me
créditer si les présidentes des flamants
roses qui gère toutes les crevettes aux
bas salaires bas réorganisons nous alors
pour récupérer le pouvoir sur les
crevettes au permis de séjour
sa demande d'asile en étant derrière
évidemment
voilà un allah après j'avoue peut-être
que moi c'est facile de parler d'accord
parce que moi je suis italienne je suis
pas l'ami grand bfm tv un fils je suis
là migrants qui paie rester je suis
l'ami grand acceptable je suis la
migrante blanche où je suis l'ami grande
qui vous rappelle les vacances
daniel j'étais cet été c'était
magnifique à et votre niveau de langue
étrangère c'est italienne belle à la
garde sa spaghetti gracias millas il ya
toujours un peu d'espagnol dans votre
italien que vous le sachiez
essayez les versants avec un sou
d'années ça marchera pas non on leur
demande mes pupilles des migrants as tu
viens de migrants ti
si horrible assez évident et vous et
c'est pas évident de venir vivre en
france
dans moi je vois pour mon expérience
personnelle là même le ministre de
l'intérieur a compris que c'est pas
évident de venir vivre en france
non qu'ils ont fait un livret qui on
peut télécharger sur le site du
ministère s'appelle vie venir vivre en
france
et voilà ils ont fait un effort ils
l'ont fait dans toutes les langues du
monde c'est mignon mais ça n'explique
rien du tout non mais ça n'explique pas
les choses dieu est important à grasse
sur lequel on peut comprendre comment
vivre en france c'est compliqué je suis
pas pour moi l'expérience personnelle
soit nous les italiens par exemple ça
nous a jamais expliqué comment se
débrouiller avec cette histoire que vous
n'avez pas de billet les français
d'après toi tu vas manger des pizzas et
des français tous découvrent à en
prendre de douche
djoko a pas d'accord vous prédis des
touches toi ça n'explique pas la vie
sociale en france que le seul moyen de
se faire des amis et picoler non ça
n'explique pas qu est que kita les
transports en commun à quoi il y en a
dans les trois ans comment quand tu
croises des français ils te disent
pardon à ces moments là pardon ça veut
pas dire excusez moi ça veut dire tout
me fait chier dégage un ouais ça
n'explique pas par exemple que d'allumer
owa on l'écrit avec trois voyelles le
prononce avec tous les moyens qui sont
pas là tu vois c'est incroyable toi ça
n'explique pas plein de choses et moi je
pense que tu vois ça n'explique pas
quels fromage de tête
ce n'est pas un fromage
mais un truc de l'horreur pourquoi vous
faites ça [__] moi je mangeais délire
français sans savoir ça c'est impossible
à définir français a alors là encore
c'est encore plus compliqué ah parce que
je sais pas même pour moi que ça fait
des années que je suis là et toi je dis
je suis l'ami grande blanche ac c'est
très très compliqué parce que alors je
suis pas si vous le savez mais il faut
au moins un million d'euros à investir
dans une entreprise pour devenir
français
1 alors la halle et appuyez vous donne
la nationalité française express même si
vous chanter la marseillaise en japonais
alors moi moment j'ai commencé à mettre
de côté
je suis à 33 euros ça va être long
donc voilà j'ai eu moi aussi ma comme
les mélanger contenter le parcours
d'intégration exceptionnel parce que
j'ai envie vraiment devenir française
kung fu et après souvent souvent les
gens me demandent pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai quitté l'italie et
pourquoi j'ai migré parce que tout le
monde devait venir en italie en vacances
n'est ce pas et en fait vous savez c'est
incroyablement une migration
ça tient à rien moi j'ai migré à cause
du cul
jimmy grille à cause de la télévision de
silvio berlusconi
je sais pas si vous avez corse où la
voix la plus conne et ça tout haut eh
ouais je le dis pu alors je sais pas si
vous avez concept c'est non vous avez là
c'est très simple je vous explique il ya
des femmes à poil tout le temps mais pas
défendre n'importe comment à celle des
femmes avec des grosses ans et des gros
coups nous en italien on appelle ça la
femme canta à céline il avait clarifié
au cinéma avec la dolce vita à vous
souvenez pas c'est les cahiers de cinéma
ce soir à mulhouse conil amis à quatre
pattes à un délai alors moi je vis
niveau j'irai garder tout ça et je me
disais
moi si un jour je serai comme ça tam tam
tam tam tard j'ai entendu
j'attends toujours on sait jamais
parce que quand même un moment j'étais
livré de montcuq alors là je me suis dit
tiens tiens en italie ça n'a pas marché
parce qu'il fait parler d'eux mais à
france 1 france j'ai une chance ce qui
est en france tout tourne autour du cul
vous arrive à a- et pourtant vous avez
plein d'expressions bizarre avec ce
monde à vous vous regardez des films de
cul bon pas vous voir vous vous avez des
plans q1
vous avez eu vous voulez vous alors vous
pouvez commencer la soirée avec un balai
dans le cul à la terminer avec la tête
al q lorsque vous avez bu plan du cul
sec qui vous en coûter la peau du cul
vous péter plus haut que votre cul vous
vous sortir les doigts du cul vais pas
savoir dans quel état vu l'absence du
bidet dans ce magnifique pays à vous en
avez plein qu un jugement
vous pouvez avoir le cul bordé de
nouilles non c'est quand vous avez vous
dit non
vous avez des faux culs des lèches culs
des pagnes q vous êtes blanc comme vécu
est ma préférée
si votre tête est malade on doit parler
a vaincu
[Applaudissements]
j'ai toujours pas compris comment ça
marche ça et bien joué et merci
infiniment de m'avoir écouté je vais
vous laisser là dessus merci beaucoup
[Musique]
ce cas
à ce petit bornes italie à elancourt ça
fait du beau et bien de la kul et dans
coup lui mais l'encours couillaud c'est
dur à dire en italien alors car là ça va
oui ça va oui est ce que tu peux nous
dire quel est ton actualité alors mon
actualité gérer prends mon spectacle qui
s'appelle migrants l'oim cern dialogue
pour parler des migrants voilà justement
sur sa ged dialogue avec moi et moi même
avec celle qui est d'accord avec ce qui
est pas d'accord et à la nouvelle scène
tous les mardis à 19h 45 écoute grave
les deux mois veut dire ah ben moi je
m'appelle carla bien qui c'est facile à
retenir c'est le contraire de carla
bruni zawawi
c'est un détail mais quand même mon gars
sont d'importance mais bien sûr j'ai
noté que les mots techniques et bah
merci beaucoup car là vous pouvez
recevoir un prix
[Musique]
bancaire
marin